russia's war against ukraine has
apparently entered a new offensive with
long-range missiles striking cities far
away from the front lines one of the
worst strikes was on the city of venezia
southwest of kiev the capital where
nearly a dozen people were killed this
past week holly williams reports
the invasion began with terror
some feared that ukraine's capital kiev
would fall within days
as russian columns moved menacingly
towards the city
this apartment building was hit on the
morning of february 26th just two days
after the war started though
miraculously nobody was reported killed
and this is the same building today more
than four months later like ukraine
itself it's battle scarred but still
standing dental clinic some of the shops
downstairs have already reopened
and after fleeing kiev in the first days
of war
orlando chumacova decided to move back
into the building
she took us up to the 20th floor to
inspect the damage but no one died
olenna and her neighbours are raising
money to patch it up i'm sure that
we are very strong people we are very
strong
country
we are united
and we will win
in the end yes
we will win in the end russia's bloody
invasion has seen millions flee their
homes
its military is still seizing territory
in ukraine's east
and cities across the country have been
hit by strikes
but in many parts of ukraine people seem
determined to keep calm and carry on
as if living life to the full is in
itself an act of defiance
these burned out russian armored
vehicles are not on the front line but
on display in the centre of kiev
objects of curiosity for morning
commuters whose lives have gone back to
a semblance of normal
olena told us her country is simply
invincible we haven't another choice
you have no choice but to fight yes and
survive yes
yes
reporting on wars can be surreal at
times and ukraine is absolutely no
exception but from what we've seen here
over several months now this conflict
has helped clarify for many ukrainians
exactly what they want for their country
and it's also revealed their strength
and determination
adriana
holly williams thank you so much